gets going on Tuesday NBA Kia tip-off
October 24th on TNT the league they're
not messing around you got the nuggets
and Lakers in a rematch of the Western
Conference Finals ring night in Denver
by the way followed by the Suns and
warriors with the addition of Bradley
Beal and Chris Paul but we're going to
start with Denver in La Reggie is Denver
your preseason favorite to win the Larry
OB again can they do it
they can and here's the scary thing for
the rest of the league
now that they've won a championship
you've got the experience of going
through it you've got young players
at the top of their games locked up the
open and tomorrow Murray who has
returned the form and now their second
line or secondary players like Aaron
Gordon uh in Murray those kind of those
kind of guy excuse me Michael Porter Jr
those kind of guys with the experience
of winning a championship is only going
to go through the roof they're well
coached by Michael Malone uh to me they
lost the big piece in Bruce brown but
the way that Christian Brown played Off
the Bench he's gonna probably supplement
those minutes uh absolutely they have a
legit chance to repeat and what an
opening game for them because think
about this I've been part of the Turner
family for 19 seasons and 17 of those
years
this is arguably one of the best opening
night
Talent bills that we have because not
only winning the championship but you
had Michael Malone doing a lot of
chirping to LeBron James and Darvin Ham
on his way to winning that Championship
uh that Conference Finals was fantastic
so that's going to be a great matchup to
get the season started Randy when you
look at the two teams in the Valley of
the Sun you look at the Valley of the
Suns the Phoenix Suns and you look at
the Golden State Warriors what do you
what are your expectations from Chris
Paul with the Warriors how he's going to
fit in and then Bradley Bill with
Phoenix because we've been reading
Frank Bogan is going to play Bradley
Bill at that point guard position so
what are your expectations for these two
teams when you got two all-time grades
in future Hall of Famers with new teams
with maybe slightly different roles
I look at the Phoenix Suns a lot like
when LeBron James took his talents to
South Beach because we were in this same
boat wondering well someone's gonna have
to take a back seat and it ended up
really being Chris Bosh right so who is
going to take a back seat with Kevin
Durant Devin Booker and now Bradley Bill
you've got three guys who can flat out
score the basketball
all three are excellent two-way players
it's going to be fun to see with a new
coaching regime how he can incorporate
that because someone's going to have to
take a back seat and be okay with that
be okay being the third line of defense
in terms of getting touches so if they
can figure that out because they're very
top heavy especially with DeAndre ayton
the man in the middle there do they have
enough debt that was one of the things
that made Denver so great on their way
to the championship they had great debt
the question is is that debt going to be
any good for the Phoenix Suns and the
internal matchups against Golden State
Clay Thompson Devin Booker there's been
a lot of words going back and forth
between them two Kevin Durant going to
be seen as former team where he won two
championships and two Finals MVP guys
this is the best NBA opening night that
I've build that I've ever seen the story
lines are there